les vraies affaires en campagne
électorale philippe couillard avait de
grandes ambitions pour le québec
et j'annonce au québec aujourd'hui on a
le meilleur plan est la meilleure équipe
vous mériter leur confiance en 34 jours
plus de 80 engagements ont été pris par
le parti libéral retirer la taxe santé
il va y avoir 50 super clinique on va
légiférer son encadrement des
accommodements
mais at il respecté ses promesses nous
nous annonçons aujourd'hui justement
l'élimination d'attac et la pratique
moyenne d'un médecin qui aura son fameux
côte d'or où ça va être fait
certainement d'ici la fin du mandat
et s'il a rempli ses engagements à quel
prix pourquoi un discours avant tandis
qu après l'élection de savoir si la
parole comme les seuls à l'embarras
c'était il y a un an
défiant les prédictions les libéraux de
philippe couillard forme d'un
gouvernement majoritaire
rapidement le gouvernement marque le
coup il relance le projet de loi sur les
soins de fin de vie les posés par le
gouvernement péquiste précédent or le
projet de loi numéro 52 loi concernant
les soins de fin de vie et adopté une
première promesse est tenue
j'ai trouvé ça d'un point de vue de
communication puis de l'image je pense
que ça renvoyait ou que le gouvernement
voulait présenter de lui quelque chose
de très positif pour une rare fois
l'harmonie règne au salon bleu elle sera
de courte durée
je vous présente le gouvernement de
l'économie et du redressement
comme il l'avait dit en campagne
électorale en présence de son trio
économique le gouvernement confirme sa
priorité de notre plan prévoit
l'atteinte de l'équilibré pour l'année
2015 2016 sans surplus alors qu'il
l'avait promis il y est tout de même
parvenu au dépôt du budget québec
retrouve un fin en 2015 2016 l'équilibré
budgétaire
je serai prête à donner un an pour pour
cet objectif-là
le programme est ambitieux la campagne
électorale ça sert à expliquer aux gens
qu'est ce qu'on va faire comment va le
faire et pourquoi on veut le faire et ce
travail là entre autres sur la gestion
des finances publiques il n'a pas été
fait une contribution additionnelle
modeler selon les revenus évidemment des
mesures qui ont été annoncées auquel je
ne m'attendais port et c'est le cas
notamment des frais de garde qui ont été
modulée alors qu'on avait précisément
dit que les augmenter en fonction du
coût de la vie
les gars de vie la nouvelle tombe comme
une tonne de briques
le tarif passera dans certains cas de 7
à 20 dollars par jour même à
l'assermentation de la ministre philippe
couillard semblait formelle et éviterait
un choc tarifaire aux familles de la
classe moyenne la hausse des tarifs dans
les services de garde passe d'autant
plus mal que les annonces de compression
se multiplient depuis quelques semaines
avec les caisses de retraite par exemple
le gouvernement avait promis de
légiférer pour revoir le financement les
régimes de retraite municipaux ce avec
un enjeu très important il le fait
malgré les manifestations alors la
motion est adoptée
on ne peut plus vivre sur la carte de
crédit mais presque du même souffle
québec coupe 300 millions aux
municipalités
nous devons faire des choix difficiles
mais nécessaires
il abolit les conférences régionales des
élus et les centres locaux de
développement et impose des coupes au
carrefour jeunesse emploi
s'ajoute aussi une importante réforme en
éducation en campagne celui qui allait
devenir ministre de l'éducation n'avait
pas été aussi précis
les commissions scolaires vont fournir
un appui technique logistique et
spécialisés aux écoles désormais les
fusions des commissions scolaires une
proposition largement inspirée de celle
de la caq sont sur la table
oui à des économies mais surtout de
l'organisation de services le premier
ministre refuse pourtant de parler
d'austérité en plan d'austérité
c'est une crise d'une vue de l'esprit ce
soldat dansant consiel courchesne est
une ancienne titulaire libéral de
l'éducation et présidente du conseil du
trésor moi j'étais rassembler plus dur
ce qui passait pour un tough même elle
reconnaît que les mesures annoncées sont
d'une ampleur rarement vue en la
question qu'il faut se poser
et est-ce que ça doit tous faire en même
temps je pense que le choc pour les
québécois ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est l'ampleur d'autant que des
ministres qui ont des portefeuilles clés
enchaîne les faux-pas à plusieurs
reprises c'est le chef qui doit corriger
le tir
puis avec son ministre des finances nous
nous engageons à faire en sorte qu'ils
se créent deux cent cinquante mille
emplois ce n'était pas une promesse
c'est une cible c'est un objectif le
point culminant de cette série de
maladresses
donc un jour drugs je m'excuse le départ
avec son indemnité de plus de 150 mille
dollars du ministre yves bolduc jeu
françois blais de ils forcent un mini
remaniement ministériel c'est la lacune
de ce gouvernement
cette difficulté à gérer sa
communication d'equipe inde équipe
gouvernementale d'équipé ministérielle
l'air couillard ne fait que commencer
mais on ne sait toujours pas ce qu'il
adviendra du plan nord dont la relance
avait été promise en campagne nous
autres on veut ramener le plein on va le
faire réussir
on ignore aussi comment ces carnera la
stratégie maritime dont le premier
ministre veut faire son héritage
personnel ce nouveau grand projet c'est
trente mille emplois
pour l'heure le gouvernement s'attaque à
sa réforme en santé
une réforme majeure qui exclut
l'abolition des agences de santé et des
quotas pour les médecins mené d'une main
de fer par gaétan barrette
mais c'est n'importe quoi monsieur bruce
veut c'est vraiment le ton avec lequel
on a transmis les décisions et et
c'était parfois brusques
mais je le répète tous les jeunes
gouvernement passe partout et de
plusieurs nouveaux ministres autour de
la table il faut faire ces ajustements
dans la deuxième année de mandat de
quatre ans ne sera assurément pas une
partie de plaisir
les négociations avec le secteur public
s'annonce houleuse
les étudiantes ont créé un vrai repère
un nouveau printemps érable le menu
législatif et déjà costaud
chose certaine il reste de nombreux
engagements réalisés au gouvernement
couillard ensemble on va s'occuper des
vraies affaires
s'il veut qu'on se souvienne de ce qu'il
a baptisé les vraies affaires
plutôt que du prix à payer pour les
réaliser et pour poursuivre la réflexion
sur le sujet si vous voulez voir
exactement quelles promesses ont été
réalisés ou non par exemple je vous
invite à consulter notre dossier web à
l'adresse que vous voyez à l'écran